[Music]
all right here we go
welcome back everybody i hope you
enjoyed the main episode with jim if you
missed it i'll put a link to it
somewhere up here and uh we're gonna now
ask him the patented trademark thrilling
three final questions of existential
reality requiring jim to look into his
crystal ball and predict the future and
two of the three questions and the first
one jim has to do with what's known as
an ethical will not a material will
where you bequeath the bbc donations and
some of your many chairs that you own
there you know to some needy cause but
instead what ethical wisdom or knowledge
would you like to impart to future
generations when you spring forth this
mortal coil as the bard said at the
biblical age of 120. ah
well um
i mean then you know so so you come from
a jewish background my parents my
father's a muslim my mother's a
christian so it's all sort of crazy
mixed up in terms of abrahamic religions
here but i'm i'm i'm a humanist
and and and in a sense
that that can mean lots of things for
different people but what i would say is
that
what i would like humanity to be
thinking is
have compassion
have kindness show empathy not because
you feel you should or because you're
ordered to or because a holy book tells
you to although yeah that's fine if you
do but because it defines you as a human
being so for me
being kind is because i want to be kind
being compassionate and and and and and
showing empathy
it that defies what i say i'd like
people to do that not because you know i
want to go to heaven or because i don't
god to punish me if i'm not but because
it defines your humanity
it's kind of like the uh sort of
self-interested but in a beautiful way
that you put the reason you do science
in the main conversation that we had uh
it's it's not only good for others but
it's good for you too i love that answer
thank you now the next one we're gonna
go deep into the future uh and you know
the movie 2001 space odyssey uh there
are these monoliths with uh sort of
primates that discover them and try to
hit it with a bone or whatever um we
don't really know what they are and
they're sort of like sentinels are they
time capsules are they watchers as
paul davies has said or something like
that as past lurkers
but i want to know if you had access to
a billion-year-lasting time capsule what
would you put on it or in it to
summarize
the joy but also the knowledge that
we've acquired as scientists uh in this
brief span of human existence
this was a difficult one i know you know
richard feynman said you know i would
just tell the world everything's made of
atoms right and and like from that
a piece of information he hopes we could
build up all our knowledge
that's that's too simple i think you
need more than that
but i don't want to sort of be putting
in a
stack of um physics textbooks either
that's sort of a bit a bit boring um i
i i'm
far too modest to suggest i put any of
my books in a capsule but
a book that i i find profound and
beautiful is actually a book by you know
our hero albert einstein uh he he wrote
the um the special and general theory
that this man here um
he wrote the general specialty of
relativity he wrote it in german in 1916
so it's very very within a few months of
publishing his general theory of
relativity um and then it got translated
into english and it's a beautiful little
it's it's it's a it's a popular science
book but it contains some
absolutely profound ideas he kept adding
appendices at the end of the book in
which he explained the nature of space
and time and gravity and so on
i think something simple like that from
which we can determine
you know the nature of space and time
is timeless and i thought you know i
don't think we you know we may we may
advance on einstein's relativity one day
we may go beyond it to something more
more sophisticated but that doesn't make
it wrong so einstein's little book on
relativity is what i would requee i saw
that it came up you're you're in luck
gym because i saw the original signed
edition just came up for sale in german
uh for a mere 20 000 pounds so
if you want
if you want you can take some of your
material well we can no i'm just kidding
i'll have a christmas present from
you can get everything you're a half
muslim half christian
i was an altar boy in the catholic
church yeah we can do everything
together
we're one two two man ecumenical uh you
know
uh collaboration okay last question
because i want to be respectful of your
time last question involves sir arthur c
clarke's so-called third law by the way
do you know his first his first law is
pretty famous and he's sufficiently
advanced technology is an insignia over
magic right his second law i love to
drop on my department chair from time to
time and it goes like this for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert
uh so these you know ritz
you're really good with those mo zeus
but his third law says the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible the of original name
of this podcast i ask you jim as a 20
year old 30 year old you go back in time
to your time teleportation device what
do you tell 20 year old jim to do to
give him the courage to do as you've
done to go into the impossible
i think it will be the advice that
i don't need to to be so concerned about
not knowing as much as everyone around
me you know
when you're starting off you know as a
young scientist you you feel somehow
that there's so much i don't know am i
maybe i'm not smart enough maybe i i'm
not working hard enough
i realize now that i can't know
everything and you know if i wanted to
if i could go back in time and and
become an expert in an area that i know
not nothing much about now i could but
the brain is finite you know we know
what we know we learn what we can and
it's okay
not to know everything it's okay not to
have all the answers is probably my
advice
yeah as i put it to uh barry barrish
when he came on a couple of years ago uh
he said he had the imposter syndrome
which you talk about in the book the joy
of science when he saw this guy's name
in the ledger that he signed to get his
nobel prize uh you have to sign his
ledger and he looked like i said i'm not
worthy
said uh barry
uh did you know that einstein held isaac
newton in the highest regard and
einstein had the imposter syndrome about
newton who he said did more for human
culture than any human before or since
and then i said barry there's a top off
to the story guess who isaac newton felt
the imposter syndrome about and he said
who and he said jesus christ almighty uh
isaac newton lived the eternal shame
that he never lived up to the ideals of
of the great uh everyone everyone
suffers everyone suffers from imposter
syndrome it's been a joy talking to you
you're one of my favorite people that's
one of the reasons i got into doing this
podcast i hope we can meet in person
someday either here in america in
california maybe
during the winter or over there across
the pond have a great rest of your day
and feel better too thank you so much
thank you very much thanks for having me
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you